science is precise as am i okay we're
talking about caustic the toxic trapper
what's the brief rundown on this guy
yeah caustic is a defensive legend he
has the NOx gas trap as well as the NOx
gastrin aid both great for area-denial
both great for kind of holding smaller
spaces you don't want to be caught in
the gas because if you get caught in the
gas not only are you glowing green but
you're also slowed and probably not
having a good time
gas town USA all right let's start with
caustics tactical ability Knox gas traps
Tate you get three of them right yeah
you get a three at one time you can drop
up to potentially six it's on a
cool-down of course but yeah the gas
traps are pretty key like in small areas
or maybe even laying behind you because
if you if someone runs by it they're
gonna trigger it it's gonna slow them
they're gonna get a little bit of damage
it makes it so that it triggers your
passive ability as well which we'll talk
about later which then makes it easier
to target the enemy the gas is really
annoying basically and you pretty much
want to do this too you know block off
doors or as mentioned earlier lay it
behind you as like a just in case is to
alarm you and your team as to someone
possibly coming from your flanks
but yeah yeah and I would say also you
know laying that down to revive a fellow
teammate right like that's the first
thing you want to do because no one's
gonna really gonna go in there sure
they're built chuck grenades and maybe I
worry about like a bloodhound who can
see through but for the most part that's
a good tactic to have to throw those
down to revive people on your team
anything else about the gas trap yeah
and on the flip side of that you know
you can throw them near knocked enemies
as well and you can shoot them yourself
to trigger them if you want to or as
bait to you know possibly get somebody
that's gonna revive them it is worth
noting again
you can't shoot them to trigger them
sometimes you know in close quarters
battles you kind of want to do that to
scare them away or to kind of deny them
that area they can't get in on you right
because they don't want to get into the
gas and to if you are seeing the gas
traps as an opponent you want to shoot
the kind of like red cylindrical area at
the bottom because that actually gets
rid of the traps certain legends can
kind of deal with them slightly
differently you know mirages can send a
decoy at it I think Wraith can sometimes
some I think blood hell might be able to
scan for them Oh interesting yeah I bet
he could
yeah and worth noting that when
disarming enemy Kazakh traps you're
gonna want to use something a little
precise not like a shotgun like I found
out so be careful how you disarm them
yeah you can also pick them up if you
decide like hey we're leaving an area
and I want to have three gas cans moving
on to the passive ability Knox vision
will keep tell me about this yeah it's
pretty straightforward basically if the
gas is triggered it allows you to see
the enemy's easier they are highlighted
in green I believe also your teammates
can see them highlighted in green so
it's kind of like a mini bloodhound alt
in a way where you know once they're
stuck in the gas not only do you see
kind of like the dot damage but you're
like oh they're gonna be easier pickings
because they're slowed and now I can
really see them and they're highlighted
for me right like that's the best part
about caustics he can live in his own
gas and take advantage of people who are
stuck in it so yeah your passive ability
Knox vision doesn't just work for your
gas traps right it also works for your
ultimate which is essentially more gas
right yeah the Knox gas grenade is a
canister that you throw into a certain
area almost like a Bangalore and
basically once it hits it spreads a wide
area of gas and there's multiple
applications here you can kind of throw
it as area-denial you can throw it at
you know maybe some knocked opponents so
that they can't get revived you can also
throw it like near you so that because
as you mentioned earlier you don't take
damage as caustic in the gas right so
then now you can potentially revive your
teammates saver because the enemy is not
gonna want to get near the gas because
they're gonna get slowed so great for
that as well as flanking I believe is
one of the tips that the game itself
says use the gas that kind of flank I
will say that with the NOx gas grenade
and even the traps though you should be
mindful about how you use it because
even though it is negative to the
opponents it's kind of detrimental to
your teammates too unless maybe you're a
bloodhound and you happen to have the
ultimate ability to help you see through
that gas I used to play a lot of caustic
with you and I was having a grand old
time it's like oh yeah the gas is great
and I live in it and everyone doesn't
want to be in it but then it turns out
your teammates don't want to be in it
either because they don't take damage
but they're like slowed but I can't
really see you can't really fight that
way
you literally can't sprint when you're
in a teammate's Kasich gasps yeah that's
that's well put and you know if you're
thinking about like the rings closing in
right and it's getting tense you don't
want to you know prohibit your team from
from having like mobility right like
there's a there's a case by case for
like when you want to blanket a whole
area with gas any other final tips with
Kasich yeah I mean I think mainly just
be smart about how you use your traps
you know trigger them yourself if you
need to because one you don't want to
really piss off your teammates but two
you want to use it effectively against
the enemy sometimes you can actually
hole up in buildings with the traps
because you know you put them near the
doors you're blocking the doors with
them and the enemies can kind of see the
silhouette and be like ah there's a
Cossack in here we don't really have the
grenades to deal with this let's not
deal with them right so good for small
areas I think but also just be a good
teammate and know where you're kind of
throwing the gas you know maybe even
tell if you can when are your teammates
to play bloodhounds so that they have a
way to kind of deal with your gas as
well mm-hmm absolutely
well great breathe it in that was
caustic for more apex legend guides stay
tuned to Gabe's life
[Music]